if you look back at news reports and
commentary at the time you know spring
2020 just when covet started taking off
a lot of experts Public Health experts
medical experts said you know the
fastest we've ever invented a vaccine is
four years and many vaccines you know
are never you know possible to be
invented or take just much longer than
four years and so there were a few
voices and some inside the Trump
Administration saying let's set the goal
to year and like because this is a
crisis in an emergency let's really move
quickly and I think they were you know
they really divide the odds and
delivered that with the moderna and
Pfizer vaccines delivered in less than a
year and I think it's a really important
initiative to learn from It ultimately
cost 18 billion dollars which at the
height of the pandemic the covid you
know lockdowns and costs to our economy
into our health we're costing 36 billion
dollars per day so if operation warm
speed just ended the pandemic you know
12 hours earlier it paid for itself and
so it sounds expensive but it has Alex
tab rocket George Mason University the
economics professor described as they
may be the greatest return on investment
of any government program in like 50
years I want to pull up a little bit of
data that you referenced earlier Alec
which is the sort of pace of vaccination
Innovation over the years this chart
shows uh go it goes from 1880 to 2020
and shows the time from the introduction
of uh disease to the licensing of a
vaccine uh that and at the top there
we've got malaria which this only goes
to 2020 there actually is a malaria
vaccine now it's not indicated on this
chart but you can see that's a long time
without a malaria vaccine and then down
at the bottom you see that tiny sliver
of the covid-19 for the covid-19 vaccine
that is just a remarkable visual there
do you is your vision that things are
going to look much more like that now as
the norm maybe not a year but you know
much closer to that than say this
hepatitis vaccine that's halfway down
the chart
yeah I think it's definitely it's a
question of political will because we've
definitely shown it as possible at this
point yeah I don't think it'll be quite
a year just because I think that's part
of that is definitely due to the
emergency environment and when you're in
normal times
um it's harder to get consensus and
coordination among the necessary
stakeholders to move that quickly but we
can definitely do much faster than we
have in the past and I think this is
where some people criticize operation
warp speed but I think it's more of a
defensive operation work for you to talk
about investments in mRNA technology and
the science of mRNA have it happening
since the 1980s and so through public
and private investments in that
scientific evidence base we were ready
when the crisis struck and so we'd
already had an mRNA vaccine in animals
and this was the first one in humans um
but then there were either Decades of
scientific literature and companies like
moderna that had not brought a product
to market yet but had raised lots of
money from private venture capital and
from the government to prepare for
future products in the market and then
when the emergency the crisis happened
there ready to to try their hand at you
know designing and Manufacturing a
vaccine and I think also people don't
realize that moderna and Pfizer and
their partner bioin Tech designed the
vaccine in a weekend like once they had
the genetic sequence for covid-19 they
designed it in less than two days and
then the rest of that process was safety
and efficacy testing and preparing
manufacturing capacity for the doses but
with modern biotechnology we have a lot
of opportunity to move more quickly and
to design really Innovative biomedical
products I was just about to ask about
the MRNA thing um I think that that's a
really good point because on one hand
you know we attribute an awful lot of
success rightfully to operation warp
speed but on the other hand also for
people who follow mRNA technology
development it was something that was in
the works for a while and this very much
got it through the finish line and
expedited development and certainly
expedited administration of these
vaccines but it is also worth kind of
splitting hairs and saying well you know
mRNA had been in the works for a while
so it wasn't totally uh starting from
scratch I pulled this article that you
this opinion piece that you published uh
with uh your co-writer Arielle D'Souza
in the Washington Post saying Biden's
vaccine project needs to be more like
operation warp speed and one of the
things that you uh point to in kind of
helping this five billion dollar
public-private partnership uh achieve
its goals would be to speed up
regulatory processes in the same in a
similar way as uh operation warp speed
did in both in developing testing and
distributing vaccines uh the and you
mentioned the U.S Food and Drug
Administration for example allowed
clinical trade of trial phases to be
conducted concurrently and so you know
FDA trials they have three phases
there's a safety phase there's a testing
phase and then there's a kind of bigger
final testing phase and some of those
were actually overlapping and so you
know we're getting into the regulatory
component here is something that you
know might be a Libertarians are perhaps
more friendly too or an easier sell than
uh the advanced purchase agreements but
for you know the non-libertarian out
there
kind of overlapping safety trials with
efficacy trials that sounds kind of
scary how how is that actually safe
yeah so I'll just say that they weren't
overlapped completely perfectly so there
still was some like very early safety
data before they moved to efficacy so
it's there's some overlap at the same
time but not 100 overlap
um and I think you know there's also a
relative risk factor I think usually the
stronger case for the the multi-phase
thing is just you know it fails to get
out of phase one or fails to get on
phase two then the companies and the
government don't want to waste money on
clinical trials you know large phase
three trials that aren't going to go
anywhere and so given the emergency
environment and the desire to move very
quickly you know having those phases run
concurrently made a lot more sense but
um you know I could see how it's not
doesn't make sense for all uh
drugs and Therapeutics going through the
system to necessarily be structured that
way in the future it just made sense
kind of in the crisis yeah and this is
also where I think we have to keep tying
it back to the voluntary aspect of all
this because if you are accelerating
things and kind of bypassing the normal
processes seems to me that that makes it
even more necessary to make this
voluntary and not be using the power of
the state whether that's federal or
local or state level to kind of push
this on to people you know it's one
thing to have public health messaging
and you know encourage people and try to
sell the vaccines to people in a ethical
true way but I think you know that
that's like you know
what I was going to ask you is like how
far this can be pushed because I I think
that for that you know one of the
reforms that's been proposed by a lot of
Libertarians is to get the FDA out of
the efficacy business altogether and
just have it focused on safety or even
make FDA certification altogether
voluntary because there's this unseen
cost to FDA regulation we think of FDA
as like protecting and saving lives but
the Unseen cost there is that there are
life-saving drugs that are safe that
just get delayed for years and years and
in the meantime people die so you could
imagine a system where you have FDA
approval and then you have the non-fda
approved drugs that people can kind of
voluntarily opt into does that sort of
framework make any sense to you
yeah before I comment on that framework
just one quick thing about another
a more aggressive thing we could have
done that we that only the UK did which
is in terms of human challenge trials so
having volunteers sign up to be
intentionally exposed to
um kova 19
um while they're participating in a
clinical trial with some of those
candidate vaccines and I think
especially what we knew at the time
usually the case against human challenge
trials is there's not a rescue therapy
that it's dangerous like someone could
could die but at that point in time you
know late spring early summer we would
get indications I think that
um young healthy people were very
unlikely to die from from covid and so I
think again I just support human Talent
trials on the principle of like people
should be able to volunteer to take
risks to protect others and they're
protecting others by accelerating the
development of safe and effective
vaccines we let people serve in the
military serve as police officers
firefighters can I ask a quick question
about the human challenge trials uh is
that would that be like
placebo-controlled would some people be
getting the placebo or is this everyone
in the trial is actually getting the
vaccine
yeah I think everyone in the trial is
getting the vaccine and you're just
you're exposed you're challenged with
the virus right instead of what we
normally do we would be waiting around
to be exposed in the natural environment
yeah reasons Ron Bailey has written
about this pretty extensively I'm a huge
fan of human challenge trials just
because I think like you know if we're
going to fundamentally be Libertarians
and in favor of people's bodily autonomy
then I think it makes an awful lot of
sense that we should allow you know I
don't know I'm always a big fan of like
Gonzo journalism just personally like I
enjoy just like you know the reason TV
film me like getting tattooed for a
piece on uh how pandemic policy hurt
tattoo shops a few years ago and there's
something
um delightful about having yourself be
the human guinea pig for fun but it's
even more delightful when you're the
human guinea pig for medical advancement
right like it's odd to me that we would
prevent people from voluntarily choosing
to do that if they're 25 or 30 and super
healthy and and feeling comfortable with
the risks
definitely and then and just to get back
to your your framework questions it's an
important one I think at the very least
I support
um moving away from the current binary
system we're in where a drug is either
declared safe and effective and pretty
much it's mandatory for public health
insurers and a lot of private insurers
to purchase the drug if a doctor
prescribes it
um or it's just completely legal and no
one can take it I think that binary
system is untenable in the long run and
now leads to a lot of the negative uh
outcomes that you mentioned and so
having more of a tiered system where you
know something that we suspect is
dangerous definitely illegal no one can
produce it or take it and then moving up
to things that we know are safe but it's
unclear if they're effective
um you know we shouldn't mandate that
Medicare or Medicaid buy that for
everyone if there's no evidence that
it's effective right
um or more cost effective than other
Alternatives
um currently available and then you can
move up that tier given the evidence
um we have in terms of Effectiveness and
cost to ultimately
um Public Health insurers being required
to pay for something I think just the
current binary system is kind of
outdated at this point like I feel like
both Zach and I are in that category of
like and correct me if I'm speaking out
of turn Zach but like super interested
in scientific innovation and doing as
much as possible and allowing everybody
to be a human guinea pig if they want to
like I love that type of thing but then
so adamantly opposed to any coercion
that that we saw like with the way these
vaccine mandates were handed down and
it's like it's funny because it seems
like so frequently the Venn diagram
overlap of those two types of people
it's really small like sometimes it
feels like it's just me and Zach hanging
out over there in that space and like a
few other colleagues here reason
um but it's funny it's like there's
there's this odd almost like reflexive
anti-tech Innovation type strain that
you see from some of the people who were
rightfully pissed off about pandemic
policy and that really bothers me
watching that play out yeah and the only
thing I would add is you know go back to
this model here we're about to talk
about things like purchase a uh purchase
guarantees and events Market commitments
that's where I S I'm a little bit torn
like is that is it a separable as we
want it to be because if you are saying
you know part of this model was that the
government guaranteed we're gonna buy X
many doses of this vaccine or you know
whether it works or not just to like
guarantee you at least give it a shot
um and if you do make it successful
we're going to purchase this many doses
I worry the the thing about that
Arrangement that concerns me is then it
creates sort of sunk cost for the
government and then there's an incentive
to push it out to as many people as
possible even if not everybody needs it
or wants it and you know it's hard to
prove that that's exactly what happened
but that looks kind of like what
happened the way it was so aggressively
pushed and mandated by uh Russia in the
workplace which I think was total
overreach and I'm glad the Supreme Court
you know knocked that one down but um is
that a danger uh because you know you
mentioned a couple different ways to
solve quote unquote market failures
there's the these purchase guarantees
and then there's things like prizes uh
which are separate from purchase
guarantees
the prizes
I that seems more uh that's something
that feels less problematic to me the
purchase agreements feel like it comes
with a lot of potential baggage but what
do you think
yeah so just to first to kind of to find
some of these terms explain for the
audience
um and market failures we just mean
things the free market you know
uninfluenced by the government would
fail to deliver on its own and usually
that's due to a negative externality of
some kind and so we've been talking I
can reference back what I said earlier
about like there's a market failure when
it comes to pandemics because it's so
unclear when an outbreak turns into an
epidemic turns into a pandemic when is
this going to end and private companies
don't have unlimited capital and
unlimited
um liquidity in terms of like oh we can
just you know waste a lot of money on a
building out manufacturing capacity on
the chance that this thing continues for
two to three years and there is there's
demand for billions of Doses and so
they're very hesitant to commit early to
lots of investment in the development r
d process and into the manufacturing
process and so I think there's a clear
market failure here where given I think
to to your point about
um you know government waste or
um we're being committed here I think
just keeping the magnitudes in mind is
so important of like ultimately
operating short speed cost 18 billion
dollars but again like it was costing
tens of billions of dollars per day to
the US economy in terms of health and
economic costs
um and so even if I know there would
have been a political problem if it
ended up being quote unquote wasted
um but the math is just so
overwhelmingly in favor of doing
programs like these
um that I think it's it's worth the
investment and another idea I think a
clear market failure is when it comes to
climate and pollution issues companies
that don't internalize the cost of CO2
emissions and that's why I gave the
um carbon dioxide removal example of
seems like a promising technology that's
just currently really expensive but if
we think that you know this is something
worth investing in
um this is one way to do it where the
government is paying for performance so
the government's only on the hook if the
Private Industry private sector delivers
on the product that the government
defined and it's in its contract
agreement so I think that's why it can
be really promising hey thanks for
watching that excerpt from our
conversation with Alex Stop of the
institute for progress about operation
warp speed the Trump Administration plan
to accelerate development of covid-19
vaccines if you liked it you can watch
the full interview right here or another
clip right here